don't see fat hi Fong hei fat Choi happy
Chinese New Year 2016 is the year of the
monkey the ninth of 12 animals
representing the Chinese calendar also
known as spring festival this 15 days
celebration kicks off on Year's Eve
people travel home reunite with their
families and eat until it hurts
and the food is symbolic you or fish for
wishes of abundance salsa or dumplings
to bid farewell to the old and usher in
the new neon cow a traditional rice cake
for greater aspirations each new year
before the clock strikes midnight some
Chinese families will sweep their house
to sweep out the bad luck others won't
wash their hair for the first few days
to keep their luck from getting washed
out during the actual holiday Chinese
families visit their friends relatives
and ancestors street festivals
firecrackers and lion dances are in full
swing but the best tradition of all at
least for the young uns is collecting
home pile or lie see the red envelopes
since red symbolizes happiness and luck
receiving a home bow is the equivalent
of receiving a new year blessing
especially since there's cash inside